okay we're gonna continue with the
retrospective on the x-men franchise and
it brings us to x-men blast stand it's
not nearly as bad as everybody makes it
out to be there's a number of things
this thing really has working for it and
let's give this a little conduct the
creative team failed and I'm not just
talking about director Bryan Singer he
took his writing team so what was left
was a studio trying to pick up the
pieces and keep the thing going now
x-men two very clearly set up Jean Grey
coming back and being the Phoenix but
you really get the sense that they
didn't know what to do with that story
you don't want honestly I wouldn't know
what to do that story either cuz if
you've ever actually read this thing the
Dark Phoenix saga it's too big and I
don't just mean it's too much to fit
into one film the way that they had
established x-men up to this point and
the realism that is grounded does not
accommodate a straight adaptation of
that so the studio was left with this
massive story not knowing how to tackle
it the people who might have had an idea
of how to tackle it all left where does
that leave them well they opted to pull
their main story from something more
recent and the idea of the cure which I
think was a very good idea to go with
and and actually used it quite well and
some of the other stuff that works
really well it feels like even a larger
scale story then x2 was and that's a
good progression the performances are
all solid obviously the returning actors
at this point know these characters like
the back of the hand the big standout
though it has to be without a doubt
Kelsey Grammer the makeup itself I could
take it or leave it but his performance
spot-on
unfortunately it's got a lot of other
stuff not working so well for it a lot
of blame for this movie it gets laid at
the feet of Brett Ratner which is a bit
unfair I'm not defending Bertran you
know the man's a hack but ultimately the
problems with this movie are there at
the script level the big one for me
being Cyclops
I understand he could only do three days
of shooting they had to get rid of him
somehow so of course they killed oh and
I don't necessarily object to the fact
that they killed Cyclops what I object
to is how casually he is discarded first
of all you don't even see it happened
you see something start to have been an
uneven cut something else so you don't
even know really what happens you get to
stablish a little bit later that yes in
fact he did die and then the story just
plows on without him there's barely any
recognition of the fact that he's dead
and it's disrespectful to the character
and to the audience I would prefer that
they not even had him at all they could
have just tossed off a line of dialogue
about how after jeans death he'd left
the team and went out on his on his own
I would have been happier with that and
another thing and this really is gonna
come across as petty but to me it just
shows the lack of care they had the
character kalisto and when she
encounters Magneto at this sort of
gathering of mutants she makes this
offhand comment as a you know aside from
you two there's no other mutant here
who's above a level four as far as I'm
concerned that's the damn midi-chlorian
moment for the x-men franchise they're
trying to take this insanely wide
variety of amazing powers and quantify
it to numbers oh she's a level five
she's a level two so he's automatically
better than no stop it that's just
callousness to the material that's just
the people not caring the Dark Phoenix
thing I get why that happened I don't
get why somebody couldn't take two
seconds and go oh wait guys maybe we
should figure out something better than
to just kill Cyclops off screen and have
nobody really care so that's where we
are with the main trilogy if I'm feeling
really brave I may go in and revisit
x-men origins Wolverine on that
frightening note this council of geeks
is adjourned